THERE IS NO CONSIDERATION ABOUT
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
THAT RELEASED THIS DOCUMENT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU, BRET.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THE BIGGEST
TAKE AWAY FROM THIS MEMO IS IN
YOUR EYES?
>> WELL, I AM SAD WE HAD TO GET
TO THIS POINT.
WE SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN HERE.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
I DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE TO DO
THIS.
BUT THE SAD PART IS I HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHEN WE SEE FISA ABUSE.
THESE ARE SECRET COURTS THAT
EXIST TO TARGET FOREIGNERS TO
CATCH TERRORISTS AND THE
AMERICAN CITIZENS THAT ARE
REPRESENTED BEFORE THIS COURT
HAVE TO BE PROTECTED.
THE ONLY PLACE THAT CAN PROTECT
THEM IS THE U.S. CONGRESS WHEN
ABUSES OCCUR.
BUT IT'S WHERE WE HAVE TO GO.
>> DID YOU WRITE THE MEMO?
>> MYSELF AND GAUDY AND 2
INVESTIGATORS.
>> DID YOU READ THE ACTUAL FISA
APPLICATIONS?
NEWS STORIES THAT WAS PUT OUT.
THE AGREEMENT WE MADE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WAS TO
TO REVIEW THE DOCUMENTS.
I THOUGHT THE BEST PERSON ON OUR
COMMITTEE WILL BE THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE OVER SIGHT COMMITTEE
GAUDY.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS
>> DID YOU OR ANYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE COORDINATE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE RELEASE
OF THIS MEMO?
>> NO, IN FACT, WE OPENED UP THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE DOJ AND
FBI FOR FISA ABUSE AND OTHER
MATTERS LAST SUMMER.
>> NO.
>> OUTSIDE CONSERVATIVE GROUPS,
GENERAL SAYING HE NEEDS TO DO
DID YOU WORK WITH ANY OUTSIDE
GROUPS IN THE FORMULATION OF
THIS MEMO?
>> NO, I PERSONALLY LIKE ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
GENERAL SESSIONS AND DIRECTOR
WRAY HAVE WORK TO DO.
THEY HAVE BEEN UNWILLING TO DO
THAT.
WHAT DID YOU LEAVE OUT?
IS THERE JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
FBI
FB
FBI'S BEHAVIOR WE HAVE YET TO
LEARN?
>> WE LOOKED SPECIFICALLY AT
JUST FISA ABUSE.
WE WANTED TO KEEP SOURCES AND
METHODS OUT.
10 DAYS AGO WE WERE ACCUSED OF A
LOT OF THINGS.
ESPECIALLY WE WERE GOING TO
DISCLOSE OUR NATION'S TOP
SECRETS.
THAT WAS A TOTAL FALLACY PUT OUT
PART OF THAT WAS WE HAD TO TAKE
THIS INFORMATION AND REDUCE IT
DOWN INTO A SUMMARY WITH JUST
THE PERTINENT FACTS ABOUT THE
FISA ABUSE.
THE ONLY AREA THAT I AM FAMILIAR
WITH THAT WE LEFT OUT WOULD BE
THE HISTORY OF CARTER PAGE.
I EXPLAINED WHY WE LEFT THIS OUT
TO THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
MR. PAGE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT SOMEBODY
LIKE MR. PAGE SHOULD BE A TARGET
OF THE FBI, ESPECIALLY USING
SALACIOUS INFORMATION PAID FOR
BY A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN LIKE
THIS DOSSIER WAS ABOUT MR. PAGE
AND SUPPLEMENTED BY A NEWS STORY
THAT WAS CREATED BY CHRISTOPHER
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
>> WILL YOU VOTE TO RELEASE THE
DEMOCRATS MEMO?
>> YES.
>> WHEN?
>> IT HAS TO GO THROUGH THE SAME
PROCESS.
>> WHEN DO YOU THINK IT WILL BE?
>> HARD TO SAY.
I DON'T KNOW YET.
I HAVE ONLY READ THROUGH IT
ONCE.
WE WILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH AND
SCRUB IT AGAIN.
LET'S NOT FORGET.
THESE ARE THE SAME DEMOCRATS WHO
NEVER WANTED TO START AN
INVESTIGATION.
THEY TRIED TO BLOCK OUR ABILITY
TO GO AND GET THE RECORDS FROM
FUSION GPS THAT LED TO A LOT OF
DISCOVERS IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
THESE ARE NOT HONEST ACTORS.
THEY KNOW THEY ARE NOT BEING
HONEST.
I GET TIRED OF PLAYING WHACK A
PLACE.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE CRITICIZING A
LOT.
JUMPING ON ONE PARTICULAR PART.
NUMBER 4 THE MEMO STATES THAT
THE DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI ANDREW McCABE TESTIFIED
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE IN 2016
THAT NO SURVEILLANCE WARRANT
WOULD HAVE BEEN SOUGHT FROM THE
THAT.
DID HE?
>> YES, IT WAS A SUMMATIONAVE
LONG INTERVIEW.
THAT'S SUFFICIENTLY WHAT HE
SAID.
-- THAT'S DEFINITELY WHAT HE
OTHER WITNESSES SAID SIMILAR
THINGS.
THE MAIN THINGS USED TO GO OUT
AND GET THIS WARRANT WAS THE
DOSSIER AND THE STORY THAT
CORROBORATED THE DOSSIER.
>> WHY NOT PUT McCABE'S QUOTE IN
THERE?
>> THAT'S A PROCESS WE HAVE TO
GO THROUGH.
THE QUOTES ARE PRETTY DAMNING
THEMSELVES.
I WOULD NOT MIND DOING.
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
A PROCESS TO RELEASE
TRANSCRIPTS.
>> DOSSIER, THIS WAS INTEGRAL?
>> YES, THE DOSSIER WAS
PRESENTED TO THE COURT AS IF IT
WAS TRUE.
THE COURT WAS NOT TOLD THAT THE
DEMOCRATS PAID FOR THIS.
STEP BACK FOR A MOMENT.
THIS IS NOT GOING AFTER SOME
TERRORIST.
THIS IS ABOUT -- THEY OPENED,
THE FBI OPENED A
COUNTER-INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN THE SUMMER OF 2016.
SOMEONE IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
USING OPPOSITION RESEARCH PAID
FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
THE HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
IT'S WRONG.
IT SHOULD NEVER BE DONE.
>> IS IT TRUE THAT THE FBI LED
THE FISA APPLICATION WITH THE
DOSSIER?
>> YES, THE LARGEST PERCENTAGE
OF THE ENTIRE APPLICATION HAS TO
DO WITH THE DOSSIER AND THEN
USING THE NEWS STORY TO
CORROBORATE THE DOSSIER.
>> DEMOCRATS INSISTED THAT THE
FISA COURT WAS TOLD OF THE
INAPPROPRIATE ABOUT A PARTISAN
POLITICAL DOCUMENT, THE STEELE
IF THAT IS NOT DISCLOSED IN THE
APPLICATION.
IS THAT WRONG DO YOU THINK?
>> THAT FACT WAS DISCLOSED TO
THE FISA COURT.
PART OF THE EVIDENCE WAS FROM A
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED SOURCE.
>> TRUE?
>> NO.
THESE ARE THINGS I SAID EARLIER.
THESE GUYS TELL SO MANY LIES,
YOU CAN'T KEEP TRACK OF THEM.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE?
>> NO.
THE COURT WAS NOT MADE AWARE.
I WOULD THINK THAT A JUDGE -- IN
CAMPAIGN.
GOING AFTER THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ADVISOR AND HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN PAID FOR THIS
DIDN'T, THE JUDGE WOULD HAVE TO
BE I THINK CONSIDERED VERY
SUSPECT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT HAPPENED.
>> THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY TWEETED OUT WENT ON TO
CRITICIZE THIS ENTIRE OPERATION.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT TWEET AND
COMEY'S REACTION?
>> WELL, MR. COMEY HAD A CHANCE
IN JANUARY, FEBRUARY, MARCH,
APRIL, I BELIEVE ALL THE WAY
UNTIL JUNE TO COME CLEAN ON WHO
PAID FOR THE DOSSIER.
HE ASKED ABOUT IT IN JANUARY.
HE SAID CLEARLY HE KNEW THAT
REPUBLICANS STARTED THE DOSSIER
WHICH WAS A LIE.
HE DIDN'T KNOW.
NOW, MAYBE HE WAS LYING.
MAYBE HE DIDN'T KNOW, BUT BOTH
SEEM TO BE A PROBLEM.
MR. COMEY IS WELCOME TO COME
BACK AND TELL US WHEN HE LEARNED
COME BACK AND SHARE THAT
INFORMATION.
BUT, I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE FBI SHOULD
NOT GO TO SECRET COURTS USING
INFORMATION THAT WAS PAID FOR BY
THE DEMOCRATS TO OPEN UP
INVESTIGATIONS TO GET WARRANTS
ON PEOPLE OF THE OTHER POLITICAL
PARTY.
THAT'S THE TYPE OF STUFF THAT
HAPPENS IN THE BANANA REPUBLIC.
>> COMEY SAID SOME OF THE
DOSSIER ARE UNVERIFIED AND
SALACIOUS.
ARE THERE PARTS OF THE DOSSIER
THAT ARE TRUE?
>> THAT RUSSIA IS A COUNTRY AND
CARTER PAGE IS A PERSON.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
CORROBORATED?
THINK THAT CARTER PAGE WHO
HASN'T HAD A JOB FOR MANY YEARS,
WHO IS A RUSSIAN SYMPATHIZER,
THAT THE RUSSIANS WHO SAID HE
WAS AN IDIOT IN COURT TESTIMONY
RUSSIAN AGENTS SAID CARTER PAGE
WAS AN IDJOT.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE RUSSIAN
WOULD OFFER HIM A 19% SHARE OF
THIS IS CRAZY.
YOU WOULD THINK IS WILD STUFF.
THERE WAS A GOOD CHANCE THAT THE
DOSSIER CAME FROM RUSSIANS.
THERE IS CLEAR EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIAN BUT
IT'S ABOUT THE DEMOCRATIC
CAMPAIGN AND THE HILLARY CLINTON
>> FISA IS CONTROVERSIAL TO
BEGIN IT.
IT WAS CHALLENGED.
MEMBERS LOOK FOR REASONS TO VOTE
AGAINST FISA.
WAS VOTED ON BY CONGRESS?
>> NO, 702 IS DIFFERENT.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> WE FOUND NO ABUSES WITHIN
702.
I MADE THAT CLEAR TO MY
COLLEAGUES.
THE FBI STONE WALLED US.
WE HAD TO SUBPOENA DOCUMENTS IN
AUGUST.
AT THE BEGINNING OF JANUARY,
REMEMBER WHEN THE FBI DIRECTOR
AND ROD ROSENSTEIN TRIED TO DO
AN END RUN AROUND OUR COMMITTEE
AND ATTEMPTED TO GO TO THE
SPEAKER SO WE WOULD NOT HOLD
THEM IN CONTEMPT?
THAT WAS NOT UNTIL JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
>> LET ME ASK ABOUT YOU.
THERE WAS SUPPOSEDLY A MEETING
WHERE ROSENSTEIN CAME UP TO YOU
ABOUT DOCUMENT PRODUCTION AND
GOT HEATED.
IS THAT ACCURATE?
>> I HAD NEVER MEETINGS WITH
MR. ROSENSTEIN.
I LIKE HIM PERSONALLY.
I THINK THAT HE CAN FIX THE
PROBLEMS OVER AT DOJ.
WE ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH HIM.
>> YOU DON'T THINK HE SHOULD BE
FIRED FROM HIS JOB?
>> WELL, THAT'S NOT MY DECISION.
ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT
MR. ROSENSTEIN HAS A LONG
CAREER.
HE'S NEVER BEEN IN WASHINGTON,
D.C.
>> YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME
MEMBERS WHO ARE USING THIS TO
QUESTION THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
IS THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE TIEING THIS TO THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION BECAUSE
THEY ARE TRYING TO PERPETUATE
THIS NONSENSE OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
THEY KNOW THERE WAS NO
YEAR NOW.
>> ARE THERE OTHER MEMOS THAT
WILL COME OUT?
>> YES, THIS COMPLETES JUST THE
FISA ABUSE PORTION OF OUR
INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF PHASE-2
WHICH INVOLVES ANOTHER
DEPARTMENTS.
SPECIFICALLY THE STATE
THAT INVESTIGATION IS GO GOING.
WE WORK TO FIND ANSWERS AND
ASKING THE RIGHT QUESTIONS TO
TRY TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT
EXACTLY THE STATE DEPARTMENT WAS
UP TO IN TERMS OF THIS RUSSIAN
RUSSIAN AGENT.
OTHERS SAID YOU SHOULD BE FIRED.
THE BARB TODAY ON CABLE TV WERE
AMAZING.
YOUR THOUGHTS IN DEALING WITH
ALL OF THIS IN THE JOB YOU HAVE?
>> YEAH, IT'S ENJOYABLE.
BECAUSE, WE HAVE THE UNDERLYING
FACTS.
YOU KNOW THAT YOU ARE OVER THE
TARGET WHEN YOU ARE BEING
ATTACKED FROM ALL SIDES.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN WE HAVE TO LEAVE